son bastante limitadas y hay que
recordar que en este destacó la escuela
secundaria
Douglas murieron 14 niños y tres adultos
después de que un exalumno de esa
escuela Nicolás Cruz que las autoridades
ya habían reportado que tenía problemas
mentales pues se armó compró un rifle de
asalto y disparó entró esa escuela y
disparó y viendo a otras 17 personas más
se reporta en lo que va del año de este
2023 más de 60 tiroteos en todo el país
y el año pasado fueron más de 600
tiroteos hay que mencionar que en el
2014 hace apenas unos años el total de
tiroteos era de cerca a 250 tiroteos una
cifra bastante inferior a los cerca de
600 tiroteos que se presentaron en el
2022 es muy poco teniendo en cuenta que
pues ahora son los republicanos los que
tienen la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes los republicanos se han
opuesto desde hace ya décadas Ah Estás a
propuestas de limitar el uso de armas de
poner límites a este compra y venta de
armas y esta manipulación de armas sobre
todo a personas que tienen antecedentes
no solamente de problemas mentales sino
antecedentes de violencia y en este
sentido el presidente Joe biden en un
comunicado y en un video en redes
sociales pues publicó un comunicado un
mensaje al país diciéndole que iba a
darle a los 49 estados en el país cerca
de 231 millones de dólares para que
crearan y promovieran leyes de bandera
roja que son leyes que fomentan a
personas a denunciar aquellos que tienen
problemas mentales para que Cortes y
para que las autoridades locales no les
permitan comprar armas y puedan poder
usar Estas armas en futuros tiro